Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click the link in
the description can get a free trial of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
Learning about ecology can make the world
look like one big buffet, except all the dishes are each other.
At the start, you have the photosynthetic
organisms churning sunlight into sugar, and
everything just cascades into culinary chaos
from there.
There’s ciliates eating algae, ciliates
eating other ciliates, rotifers and fish and
everything else that comes after.
And somewhere, reigning comfortable from its
spot in the middle of it all is this, the copepod.
At first glance, the copepod probably doesn’t
seem any more significant than any other animal.
I mean, it looks a little strange, but crustaceans
usually do.
There are more than 20,000 species of copepods
in the world, and these various species have
managed to find their way into just about
every type of water, no matter the temperature or the salinity.
There are species in freshwater ponds, species
in oceans, and species deep in hydrothermal vents.
And just as they’ve managed to find so many
different /places/ to live, so have they found
many different /ways/ to live.
Some swim freely through those waters, others
pursue a more parasitic strategy.
And some become hosts for parasites themselves,
like the Guinea worm, which enters the copepod
as a larva, and leaves ready to infect whoever
has eaten the copepod.
But however many different types of copepods
are out there in the world, they do have a
few things in common.
They hatch from eggs, beginning their lives
as a round, not fully formed version of itself.
The copepod molts several times from this
larval stage, its body lengthening and forming
more pronounced divisions as it goes through
a youthful “copepodite” stage.
And eventually, the copepod reaches its adult
form, its segmented body forming a tapered
shape encased in an armored exoskeleton.
Copepods have a very simple eye that senses
light, which they use to orient themselves in water.
A few species are even capable of something
like vision.
But perhaps the copepod’s most essential
sensing comes from its two pairs of antennae—the
most noticeable of which is that almost comically
large set that you see here.
And along the length of those antennae are
small, sensory hairs called setae that help
the copepod detect changes in its surroundings.
Now, those antennae don’t just sense, they
also help the copepod mate.
When a male copepod finds a female copepod
who he likes very, very much, he can bend
the antennae to grab her.
And that might sound like a funny detail about
an equally funny-looking part of a copepod’s
body, but it’s also part of its success.
When you’re a tiny animal trying to reproduce
in a big body of water, the vastness of your
surroundings makes it enormously difficult
to find a mate.
It would be like trying to find a date on
Tinder, except like 99% of the profiles you’re
swiping through are just pictures of water.
So when you find someone, you really have
to hold on to them.
Copepods of course aren’t the only animals
facing this challenge.
There are lots of animals in the ocean that
are just too tiny to overcome the ocean’s
currents and the way that water feels like
honey when you’re that size.
As a collective, they’re called zooplankton,
and they spend their life drifting where the
currents take them in the hopes that food
will also be there.
The zooplankton’s diet makes them a valuable
part of the ecology buffet because they’re
at that spot right next to the organisms who
start the whole thing out, munching away at
the diatoms and other photosynthesizers of
the water.
In the case of copepods, scientists observed
individuals of one species eating around 11,000-373,000
diatoms every day!
And as beautiful as diatoms are, and as much
as we like to look at them, the world would
be very different if there was no one trying
to eat hundreds of thousands of them a day.
It would be a buffet with diatoms spilling
out of the trays, leaving no room for anything else.
But copepods and their fellow zooplankton
fill that essential ecological role, acting
like a middle man that connects diatoms to the rest of us.
And somehow, over the millions of years that
copepods have been around, they have become
the preeminent zooplankton--a kind of king
amongst middlemen, dominating zooplankton
populations in many bodies of water all over
the world, including Antarctic lakes.
In Lake Baikal in Russia, the deepest freshwater
lake in the world, copepods are estimated
to make up 96% of the zooplankton population.
And out in the oceans, copepods reign supreme.
So, the question is how?
And the answer is probably much more complex
than any one single trait, especially if we
attempt side-by-side comparisons with every
single animal that makes up the zooplankton
of every single body of water.
But if we consider the ocean—the vast, vast
ocean, where food and mates both are difficult
to come by—the copepod has a number of talents
that do help it survive.
It is, for one, very sensitive to its surroundings.
Those hairs in its antenna detect predators
and prey alike through changes in the water
velocity around it.
If the copepod detects a predator, it can
quickly jump away, using 4 or 5 pairs of legs
to jump up to 1000 body lengths per second,
making the copepod much faster than other
animals of its size.
And if the copepod detects prey, it can launch
itself into a quick ambush instead.
So speed is one advantage that may help the
copepod survive.
But this organism doesn’t rely on ambushing
alone to sustain itself.
It’s also capable of a much more sustained
search for food by vibrating some of its appendages,
which creates a feeding current that the copepod
can scan and dine upon like its own personal banquet.
And these are seemingly small talents that
stack up, producing in its totality an animal
that is capable of feeding, escaping, and
mating its way to success in the vast open ocean.
And with each diatom the copepod eats, their
strange regime becomes only more influential
because one day a fish will probably eat that
copepod, and eventually another animal, maybe
even you, will eat that fish--connecting us
all to a strange little crustacean in the
sea whose kingdom has no boundary.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We’d like to also say thank you to Skillshare
for supporting this video.
The end of the year is just around the corner
and with the new year comes New Year's resolutions.
But what if this year you got a jumpstart
on those resolutions and started today?
Because, let’s be honest, probably that
would be more likely to succeed in the long term.
Maybe you’re sitting there wishing you could
figure out ways to be more productive, well
with Thomas Frank’s Productivity Masterclass
on Skillshare you can be!
He will walk you through the steps to setting
up your own Productivity System to help you
be better at making to-do lists, organizing
your files both physical and digital, as well
as tackling the dreaded world of your email
inbox.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning.
With so much to explore, real world projects
to create, and the support of fellow-creatives,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth.
It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you,
and they’re always launching new premium
classes, so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you.
If you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click on the link in the description, you
can get a free trial of Skillshare’s Premium
Membership.
The folks you’re seeing on the screen right
now.
They are a bunch of people who have definitely
like absorbed some of the nutrition that once
was contained inside of a copepod, but that
is also true of all humans.
They are also people who have supported us
on Patreon.
Patreon is a place where you can go and give
a little bit of money to the things that you
really think should exist in the world, and
all of these people really think that Journey
to the Microcosmos should exist.
And we agree with them and we’re so thankful
to them.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, hey,
there’s always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.